il ya dix jours la mort d'un enfant tué
par balle à la courneuve avait provoqué
une vive émotion dans le quartier dans
la ville et dans toute la france nicolas
sarkozy avait provoqué la polémique en
parlant de nettoyer la cité au kärcher
et bien aujourd'hui il est retourné sur
place pour parler prévention et
affronter ses contradicteurs loïc de la
mornais sylvain gautier nicolas horaires
sur place
l'accueil et froid il s'y attendait
[Applaudissements]
cela ne dissuadera nicolas sarkozy ils
font la foule et part en contact
et le ministre de l'intérieur persiste
et signe
nettoyer au kärcher mange à saragosse
parce qu'il faut une lectrice là et
alors
on nettoie les travaux ne soient pas et
qui peut s'en sortir mais après
l'opération de police massive menée la
semaine dernière dans la cité des 4000
nicolas sarkozy sait qu'il doit proposer
plus que la simple répression pour la
police je viens aujourd'hui pour la
prévention et pour les jeunes
on va pas me le reprocher
je dis pas que j'ai raison
jeudi quand même qu est-ce qui vous tend
la main la caisse qui vient la cbc
sarkozy après une heure de discussion
avec les habitants le ministre a reçu
les élus et les responsables
d'associations et s'étend ministre de
l'intérieur qu'il a mis l'accent sur
l'emploi et la formation recteur de
l'essec est prêt à mettre à disposition
des étudiants de l'essec qui aiderait
des jeunes de la courneuve
intégrer des classes préparatoires ou
monsieur le maire à rechercher des
stages fidèle à ses habitudes nicolas
sarkozy a beaucoup promis des étudiants
de sciences po de l'essec et d'écoles
d'ingénieurs pour aider les jeunes de la
courneuve la création d'une cellule
délinquants spécialement dédié à la cité
des 4000 et 150000 euros pour les
associations mais ce chapelet de
promesses là certains dubitatifs effet
les annonces il s'en va à irait bien
il distribue des sous à droite à gauche
les machins les trucs qui sait pas si
c'est ça qu'il nous faut parfois pense
plus que c'est un coup médiatique
quelque chose quoi et je pense qu'ils
puissent plus 2007 que que la courneuve
nicolas sarkozy a fait une promesse
facile à vérifier pour contrôler les
résultats il a annoncé son retour ici à
la courneuve dans un mois
[Musique]